le chagrin s'ouvre sur le lever du soleil car
même la rupture cela s'ouvre et je suis
brisé je suis ouvert vois l'amour briller à
travers mes fissures vois la lumière
briller à travers moi mon esprit voyage
mon esprit prend son envol et je ne
cours pas je suis  choisir
je sais pour le retour à la maison que je veux aller
avec Craig et avec qui tu vas aller avec Lee
je n'y vais pas je suis sûr que je vais y aller
elle doit conquérir pour une raison quelconque ils
n'aiment tout simplement pas tout ce que je choisis
pour plus ils sont beaux
ce n'est pas moi il y a ce nouveau Women's
Club là-haut près du magasin d'alcools vous
n'avez pas bien entendu tout le monde et vous n'en avez
même jamais entendu parler et si vous disiez que quelqu'un
vous aime et
si la personne est un peu comme un
ami  mais tu sais qu'ils t'aiment plus
que ça je t'ai dit que j'ai parlé à Ali Kay
tout va bien as-tu demandé non parce que
je n'en ai pas besoin
je suis libre